good afternoon I'm sorry I can't be with
you in person today but I appreciate
this opportunity to join president
Bollinger in welcoming so many of my
fellow columbia alumni and fellow DC
area residents to this Leaders Forum I
also want to commend the outstanding
leadership that president Bollinger has
demonstrated in transforming and
revitalizing the university that we all
love from overseeing the expansion into
manhattanville to addressing a range of
issues related to on campus life he has
extended Colombia's tradition of
excellence into the 21st century and he
has restored our University to its
rightful place as an academic
institution that sets the standard for
higher education in America and beyond
and for that we are all grateful and we
can all be encouraged by the great work
that Columbia is doing to bring its
leadership and alumni together around
topics of national and international
significance this gathering provides an
important opportunity to discuss and
ultimately to take action on some of
today's most critical issues from global
communications to healthcare policy as
well as the ways our university its
faculty and its students past and
present can continue to serve our
society now this commitment to
international leadership and to public
service in all its forms is what first
drew me to Colombia more than 40 years
ago at a moment to find like this one by
unprecedented challenges as well as
extraordinary possibilities for progress
now as a college student I encountered
professors and made friends who would
inspire and guide me for years to come
and whether by staging a sit-in in Dean
Coleman's office or by working with the
n-double-a-cp over the summers I began
to understand the positive difference
that a single person can and must make
in the classrooms of Columbia Law School
my aspirations for a life spent serving
our justice system took shape and I
gather the tools necessary to build a
career in the service of my country and
my fellow citizens Columbia is a special
place no matter what course of study we
pursued each of us left Morningside
Heights with much more than a good
education and a respected degree
like many of you Columbia has defined my
life and I know that you're here today
in our nation's capital because you
share the same commitment to service
that has driven generations of alumni to
become global leaders and feels ranging
from law to journalism to public health
you're here because across government
than the private sector you're
determined to have a positive impact and
to advance the causes that define your
career path I'm proud to be a part of
such a distinguished Columbia family and
I am grateful for the contributions and
the dedication of every person in this
room especially the Columbia leadership
team who organized the forum and my hope
is that the conversations that you begin
here will guide us as individuals and as
a community long after today now in just
a moment you will hear from my colleague
my friend and my fellow alum assistant
attorney general lanny breuer who has
the Justice Department's Criminal
Division Lenny knows what it means to
live out the finest traditions of
service that have always characterized
our University and I'm grateful that
he's brought his perspective and his
expertise to the department's critical
work as you move forward with today's
program know that Lanny and I look
forward to the work that we will
continue the future that we will build
together and the community that we will
strengthen through events like this
forum once again I want to thank each of
you for joining in today's discussions
and for your ongoing commitment to
public service in all of its forms I
wish you all a most productive afternoon